hello quick update i just dropped my nft
project yesterday and was pretty crazy
it got completely minted in under 30
seconds so that means we were able to
raise um
234 080
depending on the price
in 30 seconds which is freaking awesome
and uh well 10 of that goes to magic
eden 10 of that goes to my dev and then
the rest will be for video production
you don't know what this means to me
like i don't need to make videos with
sponsors anymore well
i do have two more sponsors that i
technically sign but also it means that
i don't need to care about the views i
don't need to care about clickbait
thumbnails i don't need to care about
going viral i could make videos the way
i want to make them i'm not sure if
you've seen my last video but that video
was one of my proudest videos and we
could make like 10 of these videos with
the money we raised so i'm super
grateful and i can't wait to make these
videos
if you still want to support me you
still can i mean you can go buy doggo at
the secondary market at magic eden i do
get four percent royalties so all of
that goes back to video production with
that nft you could join our private
discord with the rest of our community
and for all of the og doggos you know
who you are i just want to say thank you
for making my past week super
entertaining and also thank you for
supporting me not just financially
but
emotionally throughout this week so
thank you you know who you are oh gross
oh wait and one last thing if you saw my
last video you remember this right so i
was wondering should i frame it and then
auction it and then all the proceeds
will go to prostate male prostate cancer
research
i don't know what do you think i i think
it's i think it would be pretty cool but
yeah let me know in the comments if you
think that's a good idea if it is i
might do it all right peace